ted cruz um has gone viral
and it's not good i don't know that ted
cruz has ever gone viral for something
good i remember when ted cruz sort of
humiliated himself by apparently
accidentally
liking porn on twitter
um and then they blamed it on
a staffer or something like that
and then ted cruz went viral when trump
called his wife ugly
and ted cruz went viral when he left
texas during the power outages and went
to cancun if ted cruz has gone viral
it's usually not good and ted cruz has
now gone viral for sort of his version
of what we call the sir routine so let
me let me explain that to you
um
ted cruz yesterday
had a meeting with the dc trucker convoy
people now there's there's so many
things going on here the dc trucker
convoy is the american version of the
canadian trucker convoy who drove around
burning gas and diesel
uh and honking their horns
in a principled and defiant protest
against mandates now you might be saying
david what mandates are there are they
talking about yeah i don't know i don't
know i mean the main mandate which was
for vaccination or testing
if your business has more than 100
employees
the supreme court stopped that
uh
many if not most city mandates for
required vaccination to go places like
restaurants etc
those are being dropped
i don't actually know what what mandates
they're protesting but in any case ted
cruz met with the trucker convoy and he
claimed that flight attendants and
pilots regularly hug him they regularly
hug him
because
he fights the vaccine mandates this
almost certainly didn't happen this is a
version of the sir routine that trump is
known for take a listen every week i fly
back and forth to houston right almost
without exception every time i'm on i'm
on an airplane
either the captain or a flight attendant
will come up to me
will hug me and say thank you for
fighting for us because i'll tell you
united airlines sadly houston is a hub
of them
has fired thousands of pilots and flight
attendants now that's a lie
that's a lie uh united has about i
believe 60 000 us-based employees
and 200 people were let go for not
getting vaccinated 200 not thousands do
the facts matter probably not
what difference does it make we're in
the district of columbia right now there
are mandates affecting kids in d.c
this is wrong
so
this is a version of trump's sir routine
trump sir routine is when trump goes you
know they came to me and they said sir
sir sure
thank you for doing this with a tear in
their eye they came to me and said thank
you sir
for allowing unvaccinated people to be
all over me and spread um it it's almost
always a lie when trump says they came
to me and they said sir it's almost
always a lie when trump says and nobody
really knows that it's almost always a
lie when trump says and it's really a
shame we won this election but they
stole it and it's really a shame those
are triggers that it's probably a lie
with ted cruz
i mean i think any time ted cruz is
claiming others deliberately made
physical contact with
with him uh it's probably a lie and i
can't imagine that flight attendants and
pilots are coming up to him and hugging
him and saying thank you thank you for
allowing and encouraging unvaccinated
people to be getting on our airplanes
and often i'm guessing those are the
very same people that uh wear the mask
under the chin on the plane
uh because they just don't know what the
hell is going on or or or just don't
care but again the truth is
united airlines
96 000 global employees about 60 000 of
those i think my numbers are right
are based in the united states and of
those 60 000
200 were let go for being unvaccinated
and for a very long period i don't know
if it's still but for a very long period
of time
once united put in place their vaccine
requirement
they
their employees stopped dying of the
virus now it's been so long now it's
certainly conceivable that now
um some some vaccinated employee has
died of the virus it's certainly
possible but for a very long stretch of
time they were not uh give me a break
ted cruz continuing to just tell these
stories and by the way
why is he meeting with this trucker
convoy what i would love to see cruz ask
instead of ranting and raving in this
kind of like faux
defiant tone
about vaccines i would love to see him
ask the truckers
exactly which mandates are you here in
opposition to exactly which ones tell me
because there's barely any left and all
of the restrictions are falling by the
wayside all right so that's ted cruz
uh and um there are people who see him
as a hero
i don't but there are people who do
we're gonna take a quick break and be
back right after this make sure you're
following us on facebook
at facebook.com
slash david pakman show
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack giving you 20
off monk packs keto nut and seed bars
which taste just like your favorite
sweet snacks but without the guilt
because they have only one gram of sugar
two to three net carbs and 150 calories
a great snack if you're doing keto if
you're doing low carb and if you just
want a low sugar snack i love the monk
pack nut and seed bars great balance of
sweet and salty satisfyingly crunchy
soft and chewy because i like these so
much i use monk packs subscription
feature sends them straight to my house
on a regular basis and saves me 10
percent if you don't love monk pack as
much as i do they will refund you all
your money i think there's a really good
chance monk pack nut and seed bars
become your favorite go-to snack monk
pack is giving you 20 off your first
order go to monkpack.com and enter the
code pacman at checkout